it's been just over a week since I
switched to the iPhone 11 Pro max after
using the tennis max for practically a
year and today I'm gonna tell you every
real-world difference that I noticed
some that Apple advertised and I was
expecting and others that I wasn't but
really surprised me and even a few
disappointments let's jump right in and
I'll put it right out there the biggest
difference that actually affects my
daily life and solely makes the iPhone
11 Pro worth the upgrade from the 10s
and that is the battery life yes Apple
finally put a fast charger in the box
but at this point that doesn't even
matter at all there is no need for it
I've never had to top off my 11 Pro max
and after a week that is literally
providing a sense of relief or maybe
even freedom not having to worry about
what my battery life is that we're
having to check it throughout the day I
use my phone a lot from tons of emails
notifications YouTube videos music
podcasts and multiple apps that track my
location in the background for security
and home automation
so my iPhones battery really gets
hammered I start using my phone at about
7 a.m. and I would always have to top
off my tennis Max's battery by about 6
or 7 or else the battery would die let's
just say that I was shocked the first
night when I set it to charge at 10:00
p.m. and the battery was that 26% the
next night it was at 30% just after
10:00 p.m. and the following night I
plugged it in around midnight and it was
at 20% I have never had any flagship
smartphone performed this good while
being pushed so hard next is the matte
glass back it looks fantastic it
actually looks like gold this time and I
love that it's basically fingerprint
proof but my issue with it is that it's
much more slippery than the glossy glass
back of the iPhone 10's max
I don't use cases on my phones so that
was definitely something that was
noticeable I have to be a lot more
careful with it on hold when holding in
my hand and grip it tighter because it's
way more slippery on the front
I love the display brightness the
readability is so much better in bright
Sun it's more pleasant to use and makes
a massive difference if you use your
phone as a display for a drone
controller next let's talk about the
speakers the 10s sounded really good but
I did wish that we had more volume
particularly in loud environments and
Apple definitely stepped it up even a
week later I'm still being surprised by
them when
opening up a high quality sounding video
or podcast what surprised me even more
is when I watched the portion of the
movie 300 on iTunes I was shocked by how
good the fake surround sound is both a
separation of channels as well as
individual sound effects sound
impossibly good for a tiny thin
smartphone not that this is important in
daily use but it definitely jumped out
at me and it's something that I can
appreciate another thing that stood out
to me is the sound quality of the
earpiece speaker most of us don't talk
about call quality which we definitely
need to change but the higher quality
and louder earpiece speaker makes a
noticeable difference but it doesn't
stop there
the first time I called my wife on the
pro with her using the new 11 she
immediately mentioned how good the call
quality was and I definitely noticed it
it was an even bigger difference than
talking to other people since it seems
that either the microphone or the voice
processing has been noticeably improved
it was an even bigger difference than
when talking to other people since it
seems that either the microphone and/or
the voice processing has been improved
but either way calls are louder and
clearer now before I tell you about how
the camera updates stand out in the real
world and about a few disappointments
that presented themselves let me tell
you about our standout sponsor brilliant
really helps you excel in math and
science by actually solving problems and
learning concepts by applying them
instead of just listening to lectures
which in the real world works much
better
it's enjoyed by students professionals
in science enthusiasts all over the
world they have a wide range of content
like daily problems in math science and
computer science as well as interactive
courses from basic algebra all the way
to quantum computing now I personally
dislike learning math because many of my
classes were boring but when I could
work on real-world tasks that required
math or science I excelled and I had a
blast if that's you as well definitely
check out brilliant we're solving
problems can actually be so fun it's
addictive to support the channel and
learn more about brilliance go to
brilliant org slash Mac stack where you
can sign up for free and learn all kinds
of things and as a bonus for Mac's tech
viewers the first 200 people will also
get 20% off of their annual membership
now for the cameras everybody knows that
there is a big improvement but does it
change how you use the cameras and what
you
caPSURE in real life which might
actually be more important than an
increase in sharpness the answer is yes
first off the ultra wide lens allowed me
to capture certain shots I simply
wouldn't have been able to and also made
for some interesting perspectives second
is the much improved telephoto camera
previously I would straight-up avoid
using it and lower light situations
because the quality would be much worse
than the standard camera now not only
does a telephoto look dramatically
better in low light in the colors match
but we also have the option to take
portraits with the standard lens
this makes the iPhone 11 much more like
a real dedicated camera where you can
choose the lens's focal length based on
what fits the scene best and not what
you're forced to use with that comes the
selfie camera the quality is improved in
Apple's color processing is more
pleasing than before with more contrast
added which is great now I personally
haven't used a 4k 60 option but I did
find a useful time to do a slow fee
which isn't as bad as it sounds the
wider angle is definitely handy to fit
more people in the shots or just not to
have to hold it so far out away from you
now the camera app has also been
frustrating me it takes longer to open
sometimes just a little bit longer but
other times two to three times longer
and that's what the latest version of
iOS I never thought of myself as a huge
fan of 3d touch but now having it gone I
really miss it I would often use it to
quickly open the camera app the
flashlight deal with notifications and
more
unfortunately I highly doubt the Apple
will bring it back but this is kind of
the case of not knowing you love
something until it's gone I've heard
many people say that they didn't notice
a difference in performance since the
a12 Bionic processor is already so
powerful and while that is true I
personally did notice some differences a
part of this could definitely be faster
animations but it definitely launches
some apps faster and I saw the biggest
difference when I would quickly be
changing through multiple apps when
multitasking it is just so fluid and
quick the iPhone 11s have new Wi-Fi 6
built in but I haven't noticed any speed
differences probably because I don't
have a Wi-Fi 6 router and even if I did
my internet speed is probably limitation
but what I did notice is a smoother
transition between LTE and Wi-Fi and
vice-versa
with my iPhone 10 s if I would be
watching a video and switching data
connections I would often get
between a few seconds of buffering all
the way up to maybe 15 seconds at times
and sometimes I would even completely
have the video hang and I would have to
rewind a bit to get it going again now
this transition is noticeably smoother
and buffering is faster
unfortunately reception didn't get
better in the few parts of town I always
have issues with but it did notice
faster buffering and loading and YouTube
what issue I faced with my opponent
Ennis max is blue to delays both with my
car and with my smart lock I would walk
up to my house and some of the times I
would have to just stand there and wait
for it to connect and unlock we're now
with the iPhone 11 Pro it seems to
connect from further away these are the
kind of things that you won't see on a
spec sheet but are definitely noticeable
in real-life usage I'm very happy with
the upgrade from my iPhone 10s to the
iPhone 11 Pro sure it's not a massive
redesign but more of an iterative
upgrade with different things that make
the overall experience much better from
the different cameras with wider angles
and better quality to the massive jump
and battery life that would really help
heavy phone users like myself
this year's upgrade is better than what
people thought after the launch event if
you upgraded from an iPhone 10s to an 11
pro or even from a 10 let me know if you
noticed anything else down in the
comment section below and what your
favorite upgrade is click the little
circle above to subscribe and the bell
down below so you don't miss out on
future videos and if you want to see
Vadim's excellent iPhone 11 Pro review
click right over there this one max with
max tech and I will see you in the next
video
[Music]